you you ever there's a section of your
show you visited Slovenia it's a
horrible place it's a it's a it's a
two-hour drive from Italy who you guys
are visit Slovenia
it's just a boring like the people were
very nice and what I did get problem is
that Melania Trump is actually a very
nice lady everyone there's bike very
highly over you you have a clip here
anything we need to know for this clip
this is you in Slovenia that's right I
don't I'm not sure what part of the clip
but is part of me being in Slovenia now
let's take a look then Yanis took me to
where it all began
Mulaney is childhood home so this is the
mailbox where Milania mailed herself the
Donald Trump yes can we get a picture of
the cat Melania splat you want to grab
it a bit Yanis why not
don't find us it lets me do it when
you're famous you can do things like
this that looks like a prop cat right
that was just a lucky chance a catwalk
though you didn't set that up
no I didn't grab him by the yeah yeah I
went god I want to swear on your show
but yeah let's keep it clean so
so what happens cat walked up I always
was weird about the Donald Trump and the
grab him by the decided why not he just
grabbed him by the thing and it's like
everyone was so affair I wasn't offended
by that statement I'm amused by it like
the graph like if he said I grabbed him
by the breast you can see that right you
can't you still think it's wrong you
visually see what he might have done or
grab him by the head still weird but you
know what he did but to grab him by the
it's an inward thing right like if I
said to you I met a girl when I grabbed
it by the belly button how confused you
can feel you go did your poker and I'll
be like no did I say a poker I grabbed
that wait if he said I pounder by the
Goa palming mace but to grab a bat
that's
that's got to be one meaty low-hanging
fruit you get it I don't think you got
to ask this to Sean spy yeah Yeah right
like somebody's just giving birth and
you're okay I feel like I don't know my
crowd this evening no no Jim Jefferies
Joe is on disney/pixar
take good care you
you